The smallest possible thing
that they could do is
to just when they ask
somebody how are you?
when they walk in just
stop and look at the
person and wait for the
answer. Nice.
Break stride.
Don't keep walking for that
coffee. It's very, it's
very small. And then
listen. And as you're
thinking about connection,
contribution, calling,
control. As you're thinking
about those eight
motivating factors, if you
ask them how their weekend
is, note what are they
talking about? Did they
talk about being with their
kids? Did they talk about
doing a jigsaw puzzle?
Did they talk about just
resting and relaxing?
Like, would they talk about
a show that they watch?
Like, start to get to
know them within this frame
of what actually matters to
them? Because when we do
that, we actually can start
to move that conversation
forward in a way that
allows them to be that
full person.